glop is just the idea that when
caterpillars become butterflies they go
into a chrysalis and they don't just
Sprout wings but they are actually
reduced down to a liquid form complete
and total liquid called unscientifically
glp and then they become a butterfly and
what I identified with so strongly is
that when I'm going through change when
any of us are going through change we
might be reduced down to our lowest GL
State we might not feel great and that's
not a bad thing and anytime I felt like
I was GOP I usually try to revert back
and become a caterpillar again and put
myself back together but to look at
science as inspiration I think is really
empowering because you can celebrate glp
and decide to move forward and become a
butterfly